it is among the hottest looks in fashion
right now Western Wear is everywhere
from plaid shirts to buckles boots and
of course the cowboy hats the most
famous of which carries the brand name
Stetson suddenly the factory can't make
them fast enough Janet Shanley and tells
us why and gives us a tour
this is the sound of success deep in the
Heart of Texas two shifts working just
about Round the Clock
turning out what's been called the
American Cowboys defining piece of
attire a Stetson hat production's
absolutely crazy we we honestly cannot
make enough hats the name is Iconic but
recently it's as if Stetson is Fashion's
brand new shiny toy
Yellowstone effect it ain't a damn suit
bucket try it on
[Applause]
actors on the western drama aren't
wearing a Stetson branded hat
Yellowstone effect is real we've never
seen anything like it Tyler Thorson is
stetson's VP of marketing but honestly
the Yellowstone is just part of it
there's just a bigger shift that we feel
going on in culture
from Harry Styles to Beyonce Western
inspired clothing is having a moment
that means the Stetson factory near
Dallas is having one too what's
happening Justin Thomason oversees
production
it takes about 50 people he says to make
each hat
from sewing the sweatpants
crafting the crown so this is where the
Stetson Hats literally start to take
their shape some of the machines 50
years old but still consider the gold
standard of production
we'll kind of put kind of a rough shape
to it
put it inside the mold we'll put the
plug inside the mold now push the start
you just press the sets and hat love it
you're a professional hire me absolutely
you're hired
after a minute or so this is the result
wow the company started in 1865 in
Philadelphia founded by John Stetson who
borrowed sixty dollars from his sister
to start the company you could buy one
for eight bucks the price of entering
now is about one hundred dollars for top
of the line models more than a thousand
they're not cheap
they're not cheap there are affordable
entry points into Stetson but quality
isn't cheap the hats that you see in
this Factory are all made by hand made
in America and you know that you do pay
a premium for that but we also like to
think it's worth it who's Warner Stetson
who hasn't actors John Wayne Frank
Sinatra Steve McQueen presidents Truman
Eisenhower and Obama
more recently post Malone and Arnold
Schwarzenegger
[Applause]
sales surged after John Travolta wore
one in 1980s Urban Cowboy
[Applause]
s and went bankrupt a few years later
another company bought the license and
now makes the hats we literally have not
changed our process have not changed our
material and haven't changed our
Machinery but frankly there's probably
still some people that have made Stetson
Hats over 40 years ago that are still
here but the hatter has evolved there's
an e-commerce site and today's buyer is
just as likely to be a woman okay see
there you go
this hat just a little bit snug in the
front and back okay but you don't want
to have it tip way down the factory is
turning out thousands a week
and with hundreds of styles why not try
on a dozen or so to find the fit that
will rock a western wardrobe I like it a
lot of people that are wearing cowboy
hats that may not have thought they
could pull it off they might go with the
city hat but this is the moment we're
living I could be like for CBS Saturday
morning Janice shamlian Garland Texas
what do you think nailed it
I was gonna say I like that one better
than the first one she tried on I don't
like the flat brim yeah I know I need a
little I need a little shape you have
one I do it's I mean the couple has the
perfect hat protected from the Sun the
rain they look cool
they're just I don't have a Stetson well
do you have a cowboy hat in general I do
I do have three I'll give my daughter
I'll give you dated all three of them
you lost one at my bachelorette weekend
I know that